il ratera m'avait moi des souvenirs pas
ils ont bien tu avais moi des souvenirs
février est rendu à damas mais moi des
souvenirs family genevois mcg lancé
doivent lorsque j'étais échos les
parents
alors elle sait que le chanteur de carte
de séjour
mais est-ce que tu là ta carte de séjour
tu l'as pris les yeux là privilégiée car
il n'y a pas trop de la rupture
on dira ce qu'il est bon et le mauvais
sens moi je suis passé mais bon mais
d'après d'après
après société china org et a vécu et où
j'ai vécu dans les vosges à l'epo sur
volane en scène il m'a pas le moins
c'est parce qu'il reconnaissait pas la
bonne je connais très bien je ne sais
pas si je comprends le nom de bus pour
aller à vis policière oui parce que donc
on l'avait initié à 5 km de bus et on
allait à brodeur aussi ton après cantat
est devenu une star et où tu l'a pas
retenu a déjà été plus marqué puisque
c'était son service militaire
ah bon non j'étais ce que ces créneaux
je suis abattoirs français mettait
réforme est donc je peux pas savoir
quand la boue rouge est responsable
j'avais était venu ici à 4 7 à 8 sont
hélas bon d'accord moi ce que j'ai dit
aux jeunes des paroisses et bientôt de
ce sont les procès d'après tout ce qu'on
attend et que donc il ya pas de raison
qu'on ne se connaît pas tout
m
aux plages et aux ménages
vous voulez un enfant de mona rage
pour partager mon bonheur
aux visiteurs
mais je te vois
oui le temps
dans la joie ou la soul 1
mais quand on dit beurre ça t'emmerde
number of fame et ses rapines véhicule
je me souviens on lisait effort et j'ai
toujours vu de dehors quelques
charentes-poitou ouais parce que là
aussi il est bon les éleveurs quelle
était sa carte de séjour c'est une
espèce de tout le monde fait référence à
l'immigration et à la préfecture mais
c'était plutôt référence au roi des cons
qui écarte de saison c'est la partie tu
ou ah oui c'est le deux séjours
c'est comme isaac de bankolé qu'à
rajouter 1 2 comme avant d'en coller
pour faire un bon ben ça me garde de ses
joues c'est une référence
la nouvelle aristocratie on est les
barreaux et qu'un jour ou l'autre on
aura nos châteaux ici
en cause et lointains voyages
d'où la base d'autres cieux
mais
malraux douter ma rivière matoury
et ma maison
ça les enfants qu'elles arrivent et 20
novembre
c'est la troisième génération du val je
suis même pas si c'est la troisième et
la toile quand le pen c'est 14% sa foi
comme moi ça ne s'est pas excusé mais il
s'agit aussi longtemps que le pet il vit
on n'est pas parce qu'on pensait
beaucoup pour toi mais j'ai pas eu
besoin de chiffres pour nationale
autonome faire dès la première chanson
on a parlé parce que bon on a toujours
parlé on parle pas que de le pen au
quotidien que de nuit on parle des gens
sur l'état d'esprit dans quel état à
bien dès qu'il ya des étés des noirs et
à aider votre celi les ahlaouis quand on
a fait du str ans c'était un peu ça
c'était pour pour créer les structures
d'un côté comme de l'autre on nous dit
qu'on ne te dis vous êtes et faut les
provoquer c'est exactement ça qu'on a
fait parce qu'il ya des a réagi de façon
très très mal en disant aux trahisons et
des autres français qui ont dit oui
il a gagné il saccage
voilà donc c'est difficile nous c'est ça
c'est pour ça qu'on aille pas très bien
nous tuer parce qu'ils vont certainement
attendre les bons petits beurre quand
abonnés le dos en vision les gentils et
puis c'est pas tout à fait ça
enfin
non
villa
à
non
et je te fallait
je t'aime
un jour
beaucoup car de sa victime d'une censure
à la télé est ce que c'est
en dehors de vos qualités musicales en
emploi salaires mais je dirai ce que est
ce que tu penses qu'à une censure dans
certaines émissions où habite après ça
fait 10 ans 8 ans conçoit collabos et
qu'il ya la rame le pape ne passait pas
très mal c'est certain vous aurez les
certains
programmateurs ou est ce que c'est
c'est chouette et puis et puis encore
une une espèce de 2008 surtout des
intérieurs alors que nous que l'algérie
savent qu'ils restent les gens
incroyables
aujourd'hui cinéma américain par exemple
c'est d'exorciser des problèmes à avoir
les qualités de l'homme en faisant les
films si on n'a pas fait beaucoup par
exemple et et j'ai trouvé que des fois
nous avaient dépassées quand on voit des
gens qui ont vécu c'est bien une tueuse
c'est encore en train de parler de ça
moi je comprends pas donc ça ne sert pas
d'être d'être algérien finalement non
parce que tu disais que quand ils
vendaient des encyclopédies quand lé 19
ans tu te savais quand même dû aller
mais je suis mal extra musicales avant
ils ont regardé chez un forum et des 58
complètement j'aurai avec des copains
juifs qui se voit le côté j'avais un peu
de vie c'est bien lors du costume
quartier que ça allait moins deux
quartiers à gober qu'il a perdu de ses
parents dans la guerre du kippour
alors que son père était il était il
travaille dans les absents pas bon et
qu'un jeu
ban
r d
ok
dumont
dis-moi dernière question si demain
l'hypothèse sais pas pourquoi ya la
guerre entre la france et l'algérie
tu vas être de quel côté est la guerre
mais j'ai univers entre la france et la
victoire pour la guerre je suis que du
côté je suis bloqué la guerre entre
l'angleterre et l'argentine imagine que
la guerre on suit ton côté tu vois ce
que du côté de la paix devant la page
web